you mentioned the draft failures let's
go ahead and listen to robert kraft as
he addressed
his perception his conclusions about the
manner in which the patriots have or
haven't
mastered the draft board in recent years
really the teams who draft well
are the ones who will be consistently
good
i don't feel we've done the greatest job
the last few years and i really hope
and i believe i've seen a different
approach
this year and you know in the end it all
comes out to
what happens on the field and how well
people execute and you really don't know
a draft
how good a draft is for at least two
years
the obvious takeaway from what he said
is that it's a shot at the guy who runs
the football operation and that is coach
bill belichick now elsewhere in the call
craft praised belichick i think if you
listen carefully
yeah to what he said there he's taking a
shot at nick casario
he's not taking a shot at bill belichick
he's concerned about the approach over
the past few years
there's a different approach this year
what's the difference casario's gone and
typically in new england chris you know
how it goes yeah
the guys who are coveted by other teams
if the patriots want them to stay
they stay yeah we saw cassario's stay
two years ago when they wanted
to say we saw josh mcdaniel stay three
years ago and they wanted him to stay
this year all of a sudden cassario's
available maybe one of the reasons why
caserio is available
is after seven and nine they took a
step back and they were
self-evaluating themselves and maybe
they thought hey
this isn't a bad time for all due
respect
right but but that's how i interpret
that comment i don't think it's as much
of a slap at belichick
as it is a slap at who was setting the
table for belichick in recent years and
it was casario yeah well that that's i
mean that's how it kind of worked there
there's no doubt about that
you know it was casario doing a lot of
you know
the dirty work and hey here's these guys
this is what i think and of course bill
is watching all of them too i mean bill
bill's amazing i mean of course he can
balance all this and do it at a very
high level
and really never seemed like he's
stressed out strut stressed out or
you know uh being pulled in one
direction any other way
but i mean obviously something there
and i think mr kraft you know i think
he's taking a shot at both of them all
together i think he's just taking a shot
at the whole department
as a whole you know ultimately yeah
caserio's the guy that sets the table
but it is belichick that's going to make
the decision
you know whether it's the draft free
agency he always has the you know the
trump card to go no i know you like this
guy and i know you guys in the front
office like this guy but i'm picking
this guy
right i saw that go down one time uh in
in my my one of my two drafts that i was
there but
but the the one thing that i think's
great about new england this is what i
wanted to get to sorry for talking there
is just that
mr kraft belichick whatever caserio
they're all just so blatantly honest
that's the other great thing about them
and that's what i think you know
it makes them work it's mr kraft's not
going to be
yes he's no we haven't done well bill
knows he hasn't done well too
he knows that so he just says it like it
is they've
addressed that situation and knowing new
england and bill and the fact that he's
always looking to do
something better how can i be more
concise
you know and and be better at this
process i would think they have changed
their thought a little bit
what that is i don't know uh you know
that you know my concerns with them and
what they do in scouting and where i
think they go wrong
a lot of the time well and i think it's
a combination of drafting and developing
yeah because at some point it's a
failure of the coaching staff to take
the lump of clay that's been given to
them
because even if you maybe drafted a guy
a round or two higher than you
should have it's not like you're
drafting undraftable players
these are guys for the most part that if
the patriots don't take them someone
else will
these are guys who at least have earned
a shot in the nfl so when they get
through the door
who is in position to shape them into
nfl players who can make a roster and
who can't contribute so
i think when we talk about draft
failures chronic draft failures we have
to also add and develop
because i think that's one of the flaws
here as well because
we've seen what bill belichick can do
with certain players and i think he
gravitates toward guys we've talked
about this before who know
what they're doing sure not guys who he
may have some impatience
for because they're they're still
you know wide-eyed and confused
and they don't know how to properly do
things and belichick's like get this guy
out of here i want this guy instead well
i i mean there there's
cert like certainly something to that
you know i i do
i do think belichick is good at
developing players i will say that i do
just
because it's so about the basics and
teaching you the right way and doing
things but
i think something else you said is also
like correct here as far as you know
he's so into like you just talked about
mike like
guys that do the right thing and he does
this and when i tell him to do that he
does it
it's perfect that way to me that's where
the process goes wrong you've heard me
say this before i believe
that that it's the type of player they
bring in
to where i want to go no you you can't
develop him into anything
he's developed he's not that good you i
don't you
you took him because of character and
brains
and things like that little other
intangibles
you know that you feel like he will be
an important or be able
to be a piece that fits into the the
bigger cog of their machine and
everything like that
and that's where i always thought they
messed up a little too much value on
brains and character as compared to just
you know bottom line talent uh and that
was
one thing that always jumped out to me
in in my two years being there
yeah plenty of guys love football right
and they also suck at football that's
right
and and and and that that's the reality
you got to find the sweet spot where you
get guys who have nfl caliber ability
and have all those intangibles that they
love guys who have been team captains
guys who would play for free
guys who will take pay cuts guys we'll
play for less right all of those things
that help build
the dynasty primarily in the first
decade of the run that's when they had a
lot of those types of guys but but they
still
value that and they look for that the
fact that the patriots went
seven and nine is really what has
created this urgency because it was the
first time since 2000
they were below 500 and there was an
exchange yesterday
during this conference call that that i
want to read a little bit of it we don't
have the sound of it
greg bedard asked kraft this question
what was your general impression of the
team going
and nine did you have a meeting with
bill after the season to summarize it
what assurances do you have
that personnel realize the error of
their ways and are ready to correct them
response thanks greg i appreciate it
i'll answer your question
by saying that the 34 years before we
owned the team do you know how many home
playoff games there were
and the response from bedard was zero
actually
won do you know how many we've had since
we've owned the team the last 27 years
we've had 27 and that's when he launched
into his reaction to going seven and
nine
i'm not going to use the word for how i
felt but it was horrible of course it is
when you've established that standard
of excellence and all of a sudden the
wheels
fly off and it coincides with the
departure
of the greatest player in franchise
history the greatest quarterback of all
time and tom brady
it's going to create some angst and it's
going to prompt a reaction
and we saw the action
on march 15 16 and 17. and we got the
words after the fact
with robert kraft as you said being
candid he hasn't had to be candid
no in 21 years no and this is the first
why has he never talked like this before
cause he hasn't had to talk like this
before
yeah exactly right this is you know
unchartered waters for them
it really is you know but but but the
one thing you can
count on with new england and we've
already seen that and you've alluded to
it that they got of a point they got a
plan of attack
and what they're gonna do to to flip
their team over
you know yeah uh they they fell off
for a year seven and nine i know and it
was
and it was really close to being eight
and eight or nine and seven or ten and
six i mean there's some heartbreaking
losses there
there is but the team was you know
it was being it's being flipped over you
know they've got they went all in with
brady and everybody
for you know this that second super bowl
run
to go to the super bowl three out of
four years you know the team
had kind of come to the end of its shelf
life and they were trying to kind of
piece it together
and make it work with young guys and a
few older guys
and brady's last year and i think
ultimately that's why brady lost
i mean left you know that's the other
thing i think that jumped out to me
about mr kraft's comments
you know i thought you know one of the
things he says and i know we're going to
get to that too where he just it sounded
like
you know yeah they they they let brady
go they wanted him back but it sounded
like yeah we let him go because he knew
he wasn't gonna have a
ton of talent here and he wanted more
talent on his team right i mean that's
what it sounded like and there's nothing
wrong with that
but they were in a spot where they knew
they couldn't flip their team over last
year
they bit the bullet they went seven and
nine and now they got this money and now
i guarantee they're going to be back in
the thick of things here next year
i agree with what you said but it
reminded me of the excuse making during
the season of bill belichick where he
created the impression
that they went all in and blew out the
cap and spent spent spending right
in a way that just isn't true it's not
true right what it was
was the accumulation
of bad drafts bad drafts
failure to develop and then you've got
that young nucleus that never really
matures into the guys who get second
contracts
the guys who become cornerstones of the
franchise
so now what you have to do is you have
to go out and buy those guys on the open
market because you haven't been able to
develop them i think
that's the reality they did not go out
and and
engage in all sorts of salary cap
magic to hold these teams together no no
they were very good teams and it caught
up with them last year exactly
but it caught up with them last night it
caught up with them last year you're
right and then the lack of young
you know development i think you're spot
on right there
with the fact that hey we got a bunch of
guys that are in years six seven eight
and nine
right you know that fact there was there
was nothing in the middle to kind of
mesh them together there i guess is what
we're saying really
and that's where they are right now and
and of course they're they're trying to
correct it and i think they've gone a
long way already to
to correct it hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports